好我今天直接开始吧
然后那个谢谢大家时间
上个星期的时候其实我主要讲的就是
市场上主要是美股市场上的一个头寸
头寸的分布
所以呢这一轮下跌其实已经维持了将近20天了
从上个月开始已经维持20天
然后我们上个月的基本的判断呢
就上星期基本的判断是说
美股到一个阶段性的底部了
那么这个底部之后会不会继续会一个反弹
反弹之后会继续下跌
或者是这个
就回到原来这位置其实基本上是根据
市场基本面
就是红官的基本面
那我会尽这星期再算一下这个市场的一个头寸吧
就是包括CTA包括Gama的头寸
那么同时的话呢我会给一个我觉得红官大大致的一个rowmap
大致会怎么样
那回顾一下这个图是我在今年
今年年初一月七号时候讲的时候一个一个tell risk的东西
就是我基本上来说我的市场的观点没有变化
就是不管是这一周上一周没有变化
从年初来说我基本上就是这个观点
市场上有tell risk有伪布的风险
而且这个tell risk是那个upside和downside
upside主要在中国和欧洲
然后downside的话就是美国由这些因素带动可能会发生一些大问题
可能会发生可能不发生
可能发生的规模比较大
也有可能发生规模比较小
市场反应比较大
那么但是base case就基本的那个我们最基本的判断
美国还是不会衰退
现在来看就给出的这些因素还是不会衰退
但是市场有可能会继续敏感的反应
你可以看我这边当时列了四个原因吧
就是tell risk关税
然后移民这个是dodge
就是budget cut减制字
然后欧洲有可能发生问题
现在来看市场只对第一个发出了反应就是关税
那么其实我们今年会减少很多的移民
在美国会减少很多移民
budget cut现在基本上大家会有反应
但是budget cut没有真正的减少多少制字
虽然dodge挂了很多部门
但我觉得它政治上意识形态打击比
意识形态打击比
它真正减少制字要严重
那么对于软件行业都减少制字
就是削减制字减少浪费
这些已经让软件公司卖给企业的这些作息减少了
那么但是宏观经济上的影响
其实还没有完全出来的budget cut上
所以更大的就是对于这个的恐惧和对于这个的恐惧
那接下去市场怎么走
我觉得这些风险会议继续暴露
就说我们还是面临了
更大的downside tail risk在美国
就说如果说我们现在就是当年
当时12月份
我觉得12月份1月份我们开始说
要降低仓位
降低仓位
那么在12月份1月份
如果是降低了仓位
现在是不是进去
我还是上周的观点
如果说你做了一个是短期的操作
那么本来我是觉得
如果上周就开始直接反弹的话
那可能到现在就是今天
今天就GTC
GTC前后就是要开始小心一点
那么真正的反弹其实从周五开始
那么周四时候还在跌
周五开始
那么这个反弹时间可能会拉长一些
那我觉得你们可以在4月份
等会我会说一个romad
在4月头上之前要小心一点
那个不是说4月头上就一定会跌
要判当时的市场情绪的累积的
但是4月份有一些风险的因子
就是大家可能要关注
那么更长期如果是配置性的
那我们出来的话
可能发生问题就是看
美国会不会有这种就是伪布的风险
会不会有衰退
会不会有大的这个下跌
那规避的是更长周期的这么一个风险的话
我觉得现在还不完全到时候
那第一个就是两种情况
我觉得是可以把那个全仓位配进去的
第一个就是美国真的衰退
真的衰退市场会跌到一个
因为现在杠杆还是比较高的
区杠杆会跌到市场一个比较恐怖的地步
而且现在的区杠杆下跌
它不会是光在美国的
真正的区杠杆下跌
应该是把欧洲中国全部扫进去的
那么甚至日本中的扫进去
所以在这种情况下跌的情况下
是会有一个坑可以去买
第二个就是市场pricing衰退
但是我们判断它不太会衰退
那这样的市场时机
这样的市场时机很有可能会在什么时候到来
我感觉很有可能是在四五月份
那么这个时候可能会有这样一个时间
我觉得处于这两个时候的时机的时候
你有可能可以做一个配置
因为这个可能是更加长期的一个观点
那么这个是我上
上上上上走星期一月份的时候
那么一个看法
那么现在基本上还是这个看法
回顾一下的话就是
二三年是跟着AI走
二四年是跟着宏观不会硬着落
那么就是我们只要坚定的觉得
美国宾宏观没问题
那么在这些都是没有问题的
那么在二五年的时候是政策年
那么政策年我再补充一个
就是政策年的不确定性
导致了二四年的延续
宏观上现在还没有衰退吧
二四年延续
市场流动性还是不错
这些钱就扩张到了欧洲和中国
造成了这些国家的upside tail risk
称之为upside tail risk
那这个我再重申一下
就是那个我已经讲过这问题好多次
它是一个tail risk
是网上的spike
网上的这个盟涨它不是去世
包括欧洲德国
我多好会具体说一下
德国的这个财政扩张
包括中国的财政货币双货涨
然后给出很多的信号
那么这些都是网上的spike
不可能是一个去世性的东西
所以如果没有抓到
那就要归避它
那么没有抓到
没有抓到就没有抓到
因为这个确实时间是很难预测
说一下市场的那个总体的仓位
第一个就说
美国上周的经济数据其实不甚好
那么这个就涉及到
我讲的四月份有可能会出问题的
那个上周的CPI看上去比较弱
PPI看上去比较弱
就是这个就预示了
包括那个
星期一的时候retail sales
也比预期长
那这个东西的预期
用retail sales
私营部门的消费
那么这个就预期着美国经济数据
就是大家可能觉得它会衰退
那么会不会呢
这个不好讲
但是三月份数据会很难看
三月份有几个方面
第一个就是你比方说
现在我们之前讲到的那个软件行业
软件行业有很多公司
比方说snow
包括那个service now
甚至MDB这些
很多软件公司
MDB没有吧
但是service now和snow这些都有
就是有一些公司
它的服务商也是会给到
美国政府雇员作息的
那么这些作息呢
以前 overbooking的情况还是蛮严重的
就是可能10个人
定20个作息
就很正常
但现在都去出来搞了以后
第一个大家没人用
因为它是按照使用去消费的
大家现在政府部门里面
大家闲着不干活
就处于无声的抗议中
第二个就是
确实他们 overbooking的情况
会降低很多
也就是说美国政府的消费
不管从哪个层面
从软件层面也是
都是整个行业
整个市场行业
增长了一个很重要的原因
就是政府一直在过度的消费
在花钱乱花钱
那么这个花的钱
其实都到私营部门变成盈利
那政府花钱不一定减少了多少
但是政府花钱的欲望
确实 overbooking中欲望减少了很多
因为都在搞人家
第二个不是说
它一定马上减少了多少工作岗位
它对于这个情绪影响是蛮重要的
然后这些公司
不大会再扩张招人了
所以 payroll
因为大家有这样一个预期
私营部门的 payroll 也会下来
就是这在三月份都会发生
三月份第三个事情
就是整个股市跌了比较多
所以股市下跌一定是导致
一定是影响这些公司
就是 hiring
那二月份我们看到
这个经济数据现在是这种状况
那么在三月份的经济数据
我觉得会很难看
就是这个是大概率的事情
就是说经济数据很难看
但到三月份的时候
三月份的数据在四月份报的
到四月份报三月份数据的时候
市场会再次pricing
就是定价美国会衰退
现在其实 equity
就股票市场上的投资人
很多人都已经开始定价衰退了
我看包括在推特上
很多讲财经的都在说
美国要衰退
我现在对这个说法
还没有完全 convinced
那至少在现在这个时点
我看得到三月份经济数据差
但是还看不到美国会衰退
衰退回过头
就需要刚才这几个因素
align
就觉得有点早了
就反正前面这些因素
就是doge
什么的
那个terror法这些因素会align
那么这个不是那么容易的
然后第二呢
就是说这个时经数据比较差
那么美国整体市场
你可以看市场情绪
就是从pric的情绪
pull selection peak
到那个上星期我的Fridley reading
那这个那个情绪变化
你就是说情绪变化
确实有情绪比那个Fridley的差
这肯定不是到底
但是没有像什么08年09年这种到富二
但是呢
它的上到下速度是很快的
就这个变幅的速度
速率是一个非常快的一个速率
所以无论如何
就是现在的情况
现在的市场
去累积了很大的反弹
反弹的动能
那么我上周讲到我几个
包括cta
这没有画cta
我有画cta
我没有画cta
不好意思
那个可能用一下上周的cta
那个上周cta在这里
上周cta
其实变化没有特别特别大
就大海市这个趋势
就是说
整个趋势跟踪
两种市场上
就是被就是那个
策略性的这个大规模的融资的
这个有大规模融资的
那个基金的策略
一个cta
cta中间也包括了valkontrol
就是波动率超过一定的倾倉
那么valkontrol现在全倾倉
cta现在在做空
那么cta做空大概20个别领
那这个情况下呢
它cta继续做空
空更多
概率很低
没有办法空更多了
那整个美股cta空
现在做空20个别
那只会往上
它不太会往下
所以从短期的说
头寸确实打到底了
那那个第三个呢
就是copper 白影
我们在上周的整个
delaflow上看到
copper 白影还是很积极的
对应于去年的这个这个时段
那copper 白影比去年要多
多个百分之十左右
那么
虽然后面两个星期
大概有不少公司会减少
因为我进入那个
进入那个blackout period
所以不少公司可能不会继续那个
不会继续回购
但是下两周有一个叫做rebalancing
就是你那个panching fund
他们要买股票和买债券
那你股票跌了多了
那按照原来同样的比率的话
他要重新多配这些股票
所以这个叫
这个quarter end rebalancing
就是季度末的rebalancing
大概保守估计
现在不同的估计吧
有一些估计的会比较多
有些估计比较少
保守的估计两星期
要买40个别领
就是那个强制的买入
不管什么价钱
所以我们看到
接下去到4月初
那个强制的买盘还是蛮多的
就是你第一个cta跑不出来了
然后那个panch fund
现在有有明显的在backback的趋势
虽然一般的就是
我们叫做smi manager
整体来说是过去15天
都是在卖出的
但是panch fund
有比较明显的在backback
然后copper ban也会继续
虽然少一点接下去聊天期
但是merc and rebalancing
会有40个别领进来
所以你算算筹码吧
因为我觉得这个看
T线这些我们一般职业的
不会去看这个东西
但更加重要的是
算算市场上的筹码
到底谁还会强制的卖出来
然后谁还会无脑的买进去
你主要看无脑买这批人
那无脑买的这个量还是买大的
然后再加上
继续往下跌
现在这个水平上
就是现在百分之零
这个是gama
现在gama基本是零
负的就是零
没有gama就是市场上是neutral的
投行的这个position是neutral
它对于涨跌的这个影响
它不hedge的
就不需要去买
涨的时候不需要去买或者卖
跌的时候也是一样
那么这个gama是平的
就说很多人说
下面那个put有很多很多的
这个necative gama
就是你有很多人买了大量的put
所以他跌下去的时候
投行不停的去对冲
这个问题我觉得不是很严重
因为真的要再往下4
指数这是静态的看
因为真的再跌下去的时候
还是会有人去把这个gama去卖出来的
就是原来买put那天会卖出来
或者是有人会short的
这个是要动态的看
但是你只是静态的看的话
这个我们看从现在百分之零
往下其实它会变成positive gama
所以这也是为什么
继续往下跌有点跌不动
而且继续往下跌的时候
你会看到那个vix反而在降
就是这个在上周的时候
也是我讲的一个很重要的原因
vix往下在跌的时候
在往下降
说明有一方面就是hatch position的原因
第二方面就是还是确实有一些人
在那里卖爆
重新开始卖爆
那么这些都会导致市场在短期里面
继续往下暴跌的这个难度很大
这个是我个人感觉
我不太会去看20天50天这种军险
但是从筹码上来算
就是那么回事
那么但是这一轮反弹
就是短期的时候
你说反弹会反弹到哪里的
这个事情不太好讲
我是觉得到4月份的时候要小心
为什么
4月份有两个
第一个我刚刚讲过经济数据
经济数据在4月份的时候
爆出来一轮
3月份很难看的经济数据
那么现在至少在利率市场上
我们叫rate market
rate market我们认为是更加成熟
更加机构化的一个市场
在rate market上市场
大家没有pricing
没有定价它会衰退
股票市场开始有人恐慌衰退
当然也不是定价衰退吧
对吧
定价衰退到4800或者4800以下去了
那个rate market现在定价大概
应该是三个cud不到
三个cud不到
大概是65个basis point
25个不倒
25个一次
它现在市场定价一年
是65个basis point的这个利率下降
那么这个中间
我会大伙讲一下
美联储的一个态度
但是利率现在市场
没有充分定价衰退的情况下
三月份经济数据变得很差
会不会开始定价
那这是一方面
第二呢
这一轮很大的下跌
其实本质上最早
它不是大家担忧经济衰退
大家是觉得你的关税
会导致经济衰退
那么现在对于关税的情况
我们会比过去更加悲观一点
本来我们觉得关税
effective的
就是实际的关税增加
可能是在0.24%左右
就是这里已经是加了的嘛
这些好像现在都加
auto tax没加
那就说现在
这个quadcal input已经加了
所以说现在大概在4%左右
现在已经加了
绝tax在4%左右
所以每一个额外增加
都会让大家觉得很恐慌
那这个是恐慌经济衰退的根本原因
但是4月2号
它要出这个很有可能出一个关税的方案
就是我到底要加多少
现在从
反正我得到的一些信息来看的话
它可能会比预期要高一点
包括狗们原来也是觉得5%
4%的effective tax
现在狗们也觉得6%
6%中间是哪来的呢
主要是两个方面
就是说第一个
就是这个effective tax rate中间
包括了一些recipical tax
就是你一旦recipical tax
对于本来是觉得
你如果对美国加税
我也对你加税
但是按照Donald Trump的意思
就是它可能要pricing一些
其他国家的一些资助
或者是不公平的这些贸易条款
不公平的贸易补贴
那这些都跟你pricing进去
所以这个recipical tax
就会比较严重
第二方面的就是说
第二方面的就是
它可能会给全世界的auto
我们叫做
原来是说欧洲的可能
auto加4%的税
现在可能是全世界所有的进口的汽车
全部要加25%的税
这可能还是蛮大的
所以除了考虑这两方面的原因
还有一个你要考虑的
就是其他国家会反制
反制美国就好像加拿大一样
所以这个一旦反制
就是我加你税
你反制
然后大家开始谈判
然后再把这个税计搞来搞去
这个过程是会对市场带来
比较痛苦的影响的
因为只有中国的反制
美国是完全不在乎的
只有因为它中国是
完全是一个出国国
整个美国没有任何出国东西
是依赖中国的
但是欧洲和美国在整个产业链上
还是就是说整个产业链的影响
还是很大的
所以如果它跟欧洲之间
有各种各样的这些贸易的
这样来来回回的
将乒乓球员打来打去的话
那么这个影响的
我觉得是可能会比较恶劣
所以这个是4月2号出来
加上4月有对经济数据
所以4月份就坑下闭下
就是如果说
你们是在短期里面去吵反台的话
那有可能我们叫做力空出境
然后它接着涨
也有可能
但是重于重风险控制角度
因为你现在没有一个
狼城的view
如果你有很长期的观点
你觉得这里就是底
那个经济绝对不会衰退
那你这里买进去没有任何问题
就是说如果没有这个view
我觉得4月份是要小心的
因为万一衰退至少4800件
我说就是长期配置的
什么时候买进去
就我刚刚讲了这几个方面
就要达到这个条件
才能够买进去
那么另外讲一下美联储
就是说大家
大家其实讨论比较多的两个问题
第一个就是中国和欧洲的upside
就是upside risk这样暴涨
然后会不会造成
就是说decoupling
美国decoupling
第二个就是美联储
我先讲一下美联储
美联储就是美国经济不好
美联储如果是降息了
那么会不会把那个经济扶起来
这个问题就回答到了
市场为什么先跌这么多
市场跌了这么多
就本质上市场觉得
Trump put不在
然后J-Pel put也不一定在
这个才是市场
然后再加上你Teloff把经济搞差
所以这个才是市场
跌这么多的本质原因
为什么Teloff put不在
因为你想如果是真的
像狗们预期的10%的
reciprocal的affective tax
affective的Teloff增加
那么它对应于不0.5的GDP减少
那就已经计就变1.7了
就2.2变1.7
然后inflation要增加
大概0.8%
那么就是本来可能在2.1
现在本来预期的话
年底的2.1
不做任何事
本来预期年底的2.1
这还不算那个移民
那新的可能到3%
你让联储怎么降息
就是每年储现在
我觉得进星期三要开会
我觉得它很有可能的态度
或者是接下去一段时间态度
就stay out of this shit
就是这个我离这个
这一堆东西远一点
它没有办法做出反应
因为它不可能
它已经没有余地
去对应于这个市场下跌
和上场做出态度的反应
如果经济资本面变很差
确实inflation也会下去
它这个时候子弹要会多一点
但是现在它对于白宫的政策
也是不确定的
所以它很难做出
特别多的反应
确实经济会走软
就是你如果按照10%的关税增加
实际关税增加的话
那么确实经济会走软
也就是说每年储今年要降息
可能我觉得真的要降两次
但是长端的就是大规模的降息
确实不存在
有时候即时经济走软
所以每年储的迫子落机落力
川普迫子有吗
没有
特朗普没迫子
特朗普希望股市跌
他可以挂在拜登头上
然后明年涨上了
他在说这是我干的好事
所以这个是市场真正担忧的
而且我觉得这是一个real risk
就说至少在今年
川普迫子是没有的
明年一定会有
或者今年年底就会有
但是在短期里面是有风险
说完美联储
说一下中国和欧洲
我要欧洲伪利
那么这个是运货营
讲太多中国不太好
我讲一下欧洲吧
欧洲新浅要过议会
但是周末的大概两党已经同意了
就Green和绿党和执政党
他们互相已经同意了
不好意思
就是第三件事情
defence budget加1%的GDP
defence budget加1%GDP
然后500个别链就5000亿的基建
中间100个别链
就是到climate的气候这些东西
然后突破
原来德国每年是0%的赤子左右
突破
然后到3.5%
这个让欧洲
欧洲特别是欧洲防御股
其实涨了很多
就是欧洲资产涨很多
这个东西就是和中国
前一段时间同时公布的
就是司机消费
两会之后出政策
股市上涨
包括港股上涨
其实是一去同工的
我们去年就讲到了
中国和欧洲
是用财政政策
这都是财政政策
用财政政策去追通缩
就追不上
所以他每一次去追的时候
他每一次去追的时候
市场都会追上去反弹
觉得他追得上
但是通缩不是财政政策能追上
第二呢
美国呢
是用货币政策去追通涨
这也不一定追得上
就货币政策比
但是现在美国出了另外一些情况
特朗普出了另外一些特朗普情况
但是单就中国和欧洲来看
他们还是在用财政政策去追通缩
这是非常非常困难的
所以他是一个快速的反弹
那么为什么资金
但资金因为配合着美国
正好有一些负面的情绪
所以资金就是从美国出来
到了欧洲和中国
但是要知道所有盐的最后的核算
都是美国核算
美国一旦发生危机
欧洲和中国靠的也是美国的外貌
所以美国一旦发生危机
大家都要倒霉了
而且这个现在怎么涨
涨上去多少
下来跌了比涨了还惨
因为一旦去杠杆的话
刘东晴一定是回到美国去了
这个我觉得毫无疑问
所以很多人说东升西降了
就说我们有个长期的上涨
那么包括在欧洲
我说欧洲的问题才说中国的问题
欧洲现在你看三连五的赤字
第一波反应
市场 特别是股票市场
第一波反应往往是不对的
也就是说第一波反应
欧洲的反应是说利好
然后德国重新军备
然后重新基建
然后这个东西消费
政府消费
然后就可以像美国一样
所以我们要做做 其实不是
欧洲ECB的政策和美国Fed是不一样的
Fed直接拿美债做基础来发行货币的
所以它可以无限的其实去买美债
这个没有限制
然后但是ECB
欧洲是有各个国家的央行的
然后ECB去买每个国家
每个国家发行的债券的时候
给你每个国家加个条件5%的财政赤字
你控制在这一下我就不买了
所以它其实是一个奥斯地利的
一直处于一个紧缩的状态
德国自己紧缩
它不赤字
但是现在赤字了
但是欧洲其他国家其实是没有无限的
流动性供应场口的
包括德国
他们都是互相是有条约的
那么在德国突破到三连五以后
这个结果是其他国家突破的
你不突破的话
德国的德债已经上升了
那你这些国家的债务要怎么样
怎么去处理
对于边缘的国家
欧洲边缘国家意味着
除了比方说德国
你原来神圣罗马帝国那些国家
就是德国什么比利时和荷兰
加上法国
丹曼
奥地利这些
就除了这些国家以外
其他一边的国家
他们的赤字是一套糊涂的
就是你把德国的借债利息上升了
然后欧洲央行又不可以像买美债
去买他们这个东西
就是说我觉得
股票市场低轮反应是有问题的
欧洲还是会
我列把欧洲列成今年四大风险之一
就是欧洲就是风险
你不要不能以为
它直接突破赤字
欧洲资本市场就应该涨
它埋了更大的雷
这个雷在美国出问题的时候
是会被触发的
它本身可能没有被触发
但美国出问题它会被触发
相同
中国也是这个问题
中国你现在看它的政策出来
说我们要鼓励消费
给多少钱
中国这个本质是要给钱的
然后你在CPI现在也没有上来
你印了这么多钱之后
CPI还是负的
中国的通缩问题比预期还中很多
这个问题我就不坠述了
因为我之前讲过很多次
就三座大山其实都没有卖过去
包括房地产
包括资产负责表
包括你人口
包括你私营部门的收入
其实我们出的没有一条政策
是提高私营部门收入
修复私营部门资产负责表的
那么在这种情况下
它的消费是很难起来
那就说最后看上去
欧洲可以靠一部分的德国的
叫做Physical Expansion
就是财政扩张
但是德国财政扩张的结果
是让欧洲其他地区财政扩张的空间
更小
因为它的债息被搞上去了
中国甚至财政没有做
这个在消费端没有做
特别迷离负的扩张
这数字没有
然后最终这两个家伙
都还是靠着美国
但是美国要加费
所以我会觉得很难
就是整个市场是非常困难的
那么这两个是upside risk
就是风险
就是美国出问题
他们就会一起掉下来
美国不出问题
它可以decapel
所以decapel的问题是
看美国会不会真的掉
美国处于一个温和下跌
或者是软道落阶段
它可以decapel一段时间
美国问题越严重
它结束越早
那么最后讲一下
英特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特
尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼特尼
他要减少AI方面的这些就是过度的这个浪费的头络
但是呢他对于精源和对于产品这两段还是他重点
我觉得方向的思路走的是对的
然后呢整个特朗普这一届里面
他包括这个critical input tax中间一定是把芯片加进去的
所以他的就是对于台积电的态度
一定是你台积电要大规模搬到美国去
美国台积电有
那芯片这东西不存在一家独大
就是做芯片不存在一家独大
当年英特尔独大的时候他被迫要把AMD给救起来
你可以看一下英特尔现在状态
非常像那个AMD当时那个TAR-86架构重新使用的时候这个状态
就是说这个非常像
因为这个台积电现在必须把英特尔给扶起来的
所以特朗普他们的很大的一个想法就是把这个芯片的精源
这种制造放到美国去
然后美国收全世界的归税
现在是台湾收全世界归税了
所以所以我是觉得他长迫候选
是差不多开始准备带启动
这是一个我长期一直之前跟踪的一个一个股票
好吧
那个最后我把这个说一下吧
因为这个是那个S&P每年的这个收益吧
然后25年到26年
其实你要这么看
就本质上美股这一轮一方面是掌控制
第二方面确实是涨盈率
这和00年这个还是有点不严
你想25年到26年这个之间涨了13%
13-14%
这个就是EPS的增加
所以他本质上还是EPS推动了
那就回到我们刚才讲的
最重要的我们所有讲的东西判断的是
我确实写的也没有办法给出一定答案
就是美国会不会衰退
因为他衰退的话
这个EPS growth会变富的或者甚至变贫
那你一方面杀估值
一方面是杀Burning减少的
一方面还杀估值的倍数
所以这个才是今年最重要的
但是我个人感觉吧
美国经济就是美国S&P指数
他能够这样就是这个盈利这样增加
三个方面原因
第一个是财政中期
政府在花钱
第二个是美国AI主导的投资
就AI主导的Dominus
让大家觉得我花钱主导的
然后第三就是美国的经济的
美国的Growth
就是本身经济的Growth
这和财政也是有关的
就AI主导的投资这一块
现在看上去
次大云床投入没有减少
但是最主要就看财政周期和Growth周期
会不会被动摇
那财政周期现在也没看到动摇
就要看Budget出来
但是我觉得现在包括Dog
没有看到他动摇
那么就是增长的周期会不会动摇
如果三个都不动摇
那么Growth还是今年8%
美股的指数应该回到5000
回到6000
这个回到6000我觉得很合理
这个要看
就是整个到了
我们到4月份
风险点发生的时候
到时候再去判断
所以我讲了大致
如果说配置重新回到市场的条件
好吧
谢谢大家
我这样
我要把那个